[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
Personality YouTube star and co-host of
the YouTube podcast s station smart
money happy hour with Rachel Cruz he's
my co-host today and that is appropriate
because
today we are pre-launching the pre-sale
on Georgia's first book it is very good
it's called Breaking Free from broke and
it's got a great picture of George here
pushing out against uh the toxic money
culture to that's out there and uh this
is the ultimate uh Millennial gen Z
Guide to the things I used to say but I
say them in such a boomer way that this
is actually incredible I laughed out
loud reading the manuscript I was very
impressed with the level of research
that you and the team have done to put
into the book The Detail the backup I
mean you
destroy some of these Concepts that are
out there in such a way it is so
persuasive that you just can't do stupid
stuff anymore after reading this book I
appreciate that Dave well I you know
being here 10 years now having followed
the Ramsey plan for 10 years now me
personally going from broke to
millionaire after detaching and de
programming all this talkes ever feel
weird to say that say millionaire at
your age it it doesn't feel real it's a
number on a sheet but do people on cuz I
don't read all the comment crap do
people ever say you of course you're a
millionaire Ramsey pays you a million
dollars to which you respond no he
doesn't I wish he did that would be very
nice Dave the truth is I was I was a
normal guy with a normal job you know
marketing roles I wasn't a personality
up until a few years back and so my wife
and I who also works here we've just
been following this stuff for years and
it turns out if you just you know invest
in your 401k for a decade and get your
house paid off you can become a
millionaire fairly easily in America
today yeah there you go so I dispel so
many objections that we've heard over
the years around credit scores credit
cards auto loans student loans it's like
The Total Money Makeover meets Complete
Guide to Money meets defin print meets
borrowed future along with my you humor
and snark and uh someone said today a
good dose of the snark I released the
first chapter I read it on video and a
comment said I forgot I was reading you
were reading a book it felt like another
one of your YouTube videos and it was
the best compliment that's it cuz I
tried to write book it is it's YouTube
on paper I didn't want it to feel like a
root canal reading a financial book of
everything you never learned about money
but wish you did and so I tried to make
it to where even I would enjoy reading a
book and I hope I accomplish that you
did you did it's really really good
and uh Breaking Free from broke the
Ultimate Guide to more money and less
stress so all of those things that
people are saying on Tik Tok and are
saying on YouTube and are saying on
Instagram when you folks are reading
those you go you know that doesn't sound
right but you're not sure why George is
going to tell you exactly why
painstaking had to explain crypto and NF
and leveraged real estate and uh it was
it was exhausting Dave I'm not going to
lie writing a book it's not exhausting
reading it though I was laughing my butt
off that's good it's just too funny and
we had to go to the uh Printing World
and invent a new font for the book uh we
have officially um copyrighted now the
snark font that's right and so the book
is written in snark font that usually
happens in the parenthetical for we
looked for the sarcasm font for mine but
we couldn't get it um so but we got the
snark font for you
and so that's a that's a publishing
breakthrough that's huge and uh and Dave
you wrote the forward which is very kind
of you I don't know if you were forced
to but it was very nice of you to do
that slap your name on it I forced
myself to since I own the company but
yeah from Ramsey press you I guess you
might as well hey I was honored to do
that and I I you know as the CEO not as
an onair personality I read all of our
manuscripts of course and comment on
them and um rather bluntly uh to each of
the personal ities before they before it
makes it through an edit process and uh
then but long before it goes to print
right so um that's why I get to read you
know Dr John delon's book and I'm like
this book is going to rock people's
World on anxiety I mean building an
nonanxious life the six daily choices
it's rocks it's really good Breaking
Free from broke George camel's new book
it comes out January 16 that's right and
uh we will ship it to you then as always
with book it goes on pre-sale today
we're going to let you buy it in advance
and we're going to bribe you to do so uh
you'll get an instant access to George's
newest talk show me the money and uh
exclusive access to an online private
event a with it includes a Q&A with
George you'll get the Audi book and the
ebook when we ship the book in January
on January the 16th and whether you pre-
buby it or buy it later but do pre- buby
it please uh you part of it is you're
going to be tied into every dollar and
there'll be a QR code in the book that
lets you get every dollar uh free for
what 90 days 90 days of all the premium
features the premium every dollar that's
worth it alone even if you don't want to
read this book do it for the every
dollar bonus that's awesome that costs
more than the book absolutely and so
we're throwing all of this together it's
only 20 bucks okay so it's like over
$150 worth of bonus items when you
include the every dollar in there for
sure and uh so go ahead and pre-order it
it helps George with the marketing helps
us with the marketing and um it helps us
with the orders with Amazon all the
stuff we do to try to get a book out
there uh and I just I can promise you
I'll give you the Ramsey trusted seal of
approval George is not only Ramsey
trusted but uh this we don't put stuff
out around here like George wrote it and
we just say that's okay and we print it
now we all go through it and beat the
snot out of it it's writing a book's
kind of a brutal process at Ram I beat
the snot out of me yeah well I mean
other people were pretty straightforward
with I mean absolutely we got high
standards around here apparently saying
it's it was worth it to to make myself
better and and write a book that I wish
I had at 25 you know even at 30 and this
is the book that you can give to uh you
know even if you're older this book is
going to be one of those like finally
older you know let's say in in your
70s if you're 70 this is a great book
for you because uh the font is perfectly
sized we made sure of that at least God
George and it keeps you relevant cuz I
have a lot of Pop Culture references
Dave missed this there's one sentence
that includes four Taylor Swift song
titles and Dave didn't even catch it I
and I meant it that way caught it but I
just refused to comment on so you're
admitting you're a Swifty no I'm just
admitting that I'm not as culturally
irrelevant as you think I am but I
didn't care dang it there's that so
anyway yeah there's plenty of uh plenty
of snark in here including Taylor now he
wasn't snarky about Taylor he's trust me
I don't want the swifties coming after
me the serious truth is George exposes
the mo exposes the most common money
myths that are out there and the excuses
that are out there and he takes them on
headon credit card schemes investing
traps mortgage mythology it's all the
stuff you wish you were taught in high
school and uh some of you people that
are bitching about me being a boomer all
the time well we have the answer for you
it's called George and so this book I
called Dave Jor I think it's a
compliment but I don't know anymore I
would comb your hair carefully if that's
what you're called I'd be worried about
my haird I'm going to protect the qua at
all costs protect the qua protect the
qua ramsy solutions.com store you're
going to get knowledge and confidence
with this Breaking Free from broke the
Ultimate Guide to more money and less
stress Damon John Mike R Graham Stefan
the minimalist and Rachel Cruz are on
the back endorsing and saying it's
awesome because it is this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's back by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining usle
8825 5225 Amber is in Houston Texas hi
Amber how are
you oh Uncle Dave I have a bit of a
heart uh heartbreak um I'm calling
for your advice regarding my father's uh
finances please okay what's going on um
he well we he has three different credit
cards in the total of
$26,000 he's fallen for every scan he's
81 years old he's fallen for he's made
every Nigerian prince Rich at this point
wow we're intervening in his finances so
his bills we can help with his bills we
can help he's got his mortgage covered
with social Social Security uh bills are
2300 approximately he brings in
$291 the total credit card outstanding
amount is
26,000 and we don't know at this point
whether he should declare bankruptcy or
we should let those credit cards go into
default and try to negotiate with the
collectors I'm just not sure how to help
with those
things I'm I'm guessing he has no money
he has no money he brings in uh 1926 in
Social Security yeah what what's the
what's the house
worth a lot we're trying to keep it the
house 550 probably okay what's the o on
it it's
340 okay all right in Te is he in
Texas no Oregon
okay ah
okay well I I am not I happen to know
Texas law because it's unusual I don't
know Oregon's law but I suspect it's a
standard a fairly normal state which
would mean that they eventually could
take a lean against his house if they
sue him okay if you don't pay him and
they sue him and take a lean against his
house he has no money to pay them
there's no money in this
budget right and he has no money does he
have a car right
uh not one that's worth anything no he
has a vehicle but my brother gave it to
him it's on its last legs like $1,000 or
something yes under three yes okay all
right um and you have
siblings yes okay uh how are the
siblings as far as money do you have any
do they have any can can we get a can we
get a group together and chip in and
come up with 10 grand and settle $26,000
with a bad credit card debt
yes okay yeah let it go bad Let It Go
bad and then go settle it before they
take it before they take a lean on his
house so go bad don't pay the minimum
you don't have he don't have money to
pay the
minimum with with the numbers you gave
me he can barely pay the house payment
and
eat right he's been working physically
as 81 trying to make the payments yeah
so he's been bringing in a little bit to
cover but we've been making up the
differ
yeah okay so let it go to collections
and then just fight it out with settle
it out sell it out for a quarter on the
dollar for cash destroy his credit so he
can't get anymore in the process yeah
that's what that does it's is he living
alone he is right now we plan on moving
there in three years um but so we've
taken I've taken over his finances we've
cut credit cards he he had every SP wear
on his computer so we're trying to get
rid of that well what's his mortgage
payment cuz my worry is his expenses
keep going up he makes the same amount
of money you guys are chipping in for
the next 10 20 years to try to support
his lifestyle which ain't much that's
what my husband says that he needs to
sell the house and make other payments
we're trying to this is his family home
and so we're it's nostalgic to us then
mortgage is 1756 to answer your question
goodness so he has 2,000 coming in 1756
going to mortgage he doesn't have the
money to eat then does
he no and so we're putting in ,000
dollar to cover his bills and well that
Nostalgia is going to get replaced with
this core memory and so I'd rather sell
the house and have him retire with
dignity than have your Nostalgia tied up
in this keeping him in this awful
situation you're paying the
Thousand yes my brother and I oh your
brother and I is just two of you
um there are three of us but only two
that are financially stable okay and the
um you have a written agreement where
you recoup that when he passes before we
start splitting the house Equity
up no we thought about putting into the
trust and getting the name the home into
our name so he can't I'm talking about
your other sibling shouldn't get a third
uh until you get your $1,000 a month
back we haven't yet no we yeah I know
you're right yeah I am right and this is
going to come up later and it's going to
get it's going to get real testy later
when the one that doesn't have any money
thinks that she hit the lotto or he hit
the lotto when the house is up for sale
and Pap has died oh so please get this
dialed in the right thing to do
financially is sell the
house and help him make a transition
into another place that he pays cash for
and you pay off these debts and we put
him on on a budget that's the right
thing to do mathematically what I'm
describing with an 82y old is very very
difficult yes
emotionally Family House Nostalgia all
the things we're talking about here so
what probably will happen is you all
will limp along feeding this at $1,000 a
month and you'll chip in and get
$10,000 together to knock out the
$26,000 in bad old credit card debt his
credit will be destroyed when he pass as
you'll sell the house recoup the $10,000
plus the $1,000 a month that you put in
before you split with your sibling who's
not putting anything in and that's all
in writing now if you're willing to feed
it to that tune just to keep him in the
house the only reason you're doing that
by the way there's only one reason
you're doing that that's to keep him in
the
house yes so the strain that you're
putting on your brother's finances and
your finances to do all of that is only
to keep your dad in this house which if
you've got $2 million it's no big deal
if you got 20,000 bucks and you're
throwing a th000 of it that's that's a
lot we have a million and 401K yeah we
plan but but our daily you know my
budget is dialed in yeah we have 50 we
follow your plan so we have 15 going
into we just make sure you you've got to
go do your paperwork now and if Dad will
not give you to sign over full power
ofne jne and um all decision-making
rights to you and your brother and your
sister will not understand or your
brother whatever the third one is agreed
to you recoup before you split uh in
writing then any of those end this
discussion and we sell the
house I understand okay make it Crystal
Clear yeah everyone needs to have every
Tac crossed every eye dotted and
everyone is on the same page and
discussing this cuz your dad's of his
right mind he's just susceptible to
scams yes he's not he's not like in
third stage dementia or something right
not yet no okay all right so and you
know he's 82 so statistically you're
going to do this for two years or so I
don't know what his health is like but
he could do it for 10 georg's right
could do it for 20 George is right those
are possibilities but statistically you
know we're not doing this for a long
long time and the other thing you I
would be real clear on is this is what
we're going to do for now we reserve the
right to decide to sell the house
later like you you may reach the end of
your rope on this your husband might
your brother might well and that from a
husband's standpoint if it were your
wife and your in-laws and you see
financially this is a poor decision that
would really be I don't think it's a
poor decision because you're going to
get your money back out of the equity
and basically you're C you're putting a
strain on your cash flow but you're not
it's not costing you anything at the end
of the story
and the strain on the cash flow is in
return for your dad getting to live out
his last days in in his family home
that's the trade you're making and I
don't necessarily think that's a bad
trade as long as everybody's on board
and everybody's signing up for this but
Dad you do one more stupid scam we're
done uh sister brother you don't agree
to a recoup we're done you're not going
to live on a budget and we're going to
pay your house payment you're going to
and I'm going to manage your money
you're going to sign over a power of ER
we're done we're done there are there
are stipulations to play in this through
and putting the strain on our
[Music]
family
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
George camel Ramsey personality soon to
be number one bestselling author is my
co-host today on the stage in the ramsy
solutions Lobby we have a very special
guest uh on the debt free stage if you
didn't know money problems are the
number one thing that stresses out
employees and team members at your
company and if you didn't know we help
companies big companies and small
companies with that by providing an HR
benefit to them called smart dollar that
allows them to have their team members
go through our curriculum it's kind of
like financial piece at work sort of but
a little different but I mean it's us
teaching you how to B own budget how to
get out of debt how to live on less than
you make all that kind of stuff and uh
and it's fun it's taught by me and
George and Rachel and so on and so um
it's pretty incredible one of the
companies that has had all of their team
go through smart dollar and provided it
to them as a benefit at no cost to the
employee is U-Haul U-Haul is a great
company by the way we've had a lot of
interaction with them over the last
couple of years they do a great job and
um so for U-Haul team members that's
translated uh to a combined $6.7 million
in debt paid and in dollars saved that
means that those team members are not
stressed about money so while they're at
work they're thinking about work instead
of
MasterCard TAA productivity goes up
that's how that stuff works so this is
the deal so all of that to say our debt
free scream is from a U-Haul team member
and that's Chris and Jessica where do
you guys live elk grve California okay
so you're not in the home office home
office is Phoenix Right correct okay
cool how long you been with U-Haul 23
years wow that's a long time so they
come in and go da da smart dollars here
had you ever heard of us when they
presented all this no I have not oh so
it's all brand new yes so company
benefit which kind of could be like a
little bit of an eye roll like a little
bit like uh what is this what are you
guys a little snake oil that's what I
would do right did you do that a little
bit that's what I did cuz I was the one
that go Jessica I like someone with the
gift of cynicism good for you but you
gave it a shot anyway but you gave it a
shot anyway so Chris says okay company's
providing this it doesn't cost anything
we might as well try it what' you tell
her Chris I was at a conference when I
learned about it and so when I got home
my bride idea of let's get out of debt
when she's the one that does all the
books and so I come home with great idea
now you're a genius yeah okay and she
kind of looked at me like no you don't
know what you're talking about yeah stay
away from my stuff I got to figure out
yeah so how did y'all decide to actually
take the class um it was more of me
watching YouTube listening to the
podcast getting her stuck in the car to
listen to it as well so you kind of
sampled some of our stuff in the market
and then that enabled you to plug back
into smart dollar at U-Haul yep okay
very cool so Jessica what convinced you
to actually try it at try the actual
smart dollar thing which you're watching
YouTube listen to the podcast what
happened it didn't cost anything so what
could it hurt ah except that they might
have some weird
ideas thank God you and I are both smart
but yeah we're at least we're not at
least we're not cuz I'm bet you we were
on the same team weren't we yes we were
okay all right so as long as you both
wanted to get out of debt you're like
all right he's making sense let's do
this thing absolutely how much debt did
you guys have combined we had
$291,000 wow and what did that include
uh we had a rental house that had
$180,000 uh we have a travel trailer
that was about 7,000 remaining and
73,000 in credit cards wow the credit
cards were kicking your butt yep yes
they were did you sell the did you sell
the rental house for pay it off we sold
it sold it March of 2020
oo that was my birthday present Mike
drop on the timing though wow 1,000% yes
wow thank you Jesus oh my goodness if my
prayers were to be answered it was that
day because the people that were renting
the home um were in the restaurant
interest
IND industry oh yeah which means they
lost their jobs in the fouchy pandemic
yep oh my gosh so how long did this take
to pay off 291 no they sold us house was
180 right so you had 75 in credit card
debt and then you had to plow through
the other how long did it take to pay
off that other debt the remaining debt
21 months 21 months good for you good
for you well because U-Haul all of
U-Haul is going through this uh we're
going to treat you all like we treat a
ramsy team member when they're doing
their debt free scream we're not going
to ask your income cuz all your buddies
are going to be watching this and
they're going to go I know what Chris
makes now and we're not doing that so uh
we're going to give we're going to give
you a little uh give you a little break
on that but congratulations what do you
do for a living Jessica I raise our
children yay awesome yes fulltime
domestic engineer I love it good for you
our CEO so now that you went through
smart dollar um and you pay off 291,000
including the sale of 185 you pay off
travel trailer and credit cards by the
hard way uh well I guess probably got a
little Equity out of the rental right to
throw at it about 43,000 okay so that
jumped up some of it and then the rest
of it you just budgeted through right
yep what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is cut up your
credit cards and don't get them anymore
um but just really cold turkey no
plastic surgery yeah did a lot of that
just seeing it on paper and really
getting sick at how much we had and
going what
what did we buy like where is all this
Stu going yeah so it was just it was
Freedom finally getting the app using a
budget and seeing your money's actually
going somewhere that you don't want it
to go so the every dollar app y yep yeah
okay getting it transitioned to putting
it where we actually need the money to
go versus the restaurant here Amazon
there Target whatever um by getting on a
budget and actually knowing where every
dollar goes allowed us to kind of get a
raise as we cut One credit card we have
more money next thing no we're just
rolling and kept that snowball going
till it was all gone wow was there an
extra layer of accountability with team
members and HR was it kind of like all
right we got to do this thing um I think
the the kids were the biggest motivation
um knowing that they're getting older
that if we didn't do this college was
going to be a lot harder to do um
setting them up for Success so they
weren't going down the same path as us
was kind of the motivation to keep going
and get it done even faster because all
the other ways we did didn't work that's
a strong why changing the family
tree yeah and we got a phone call this
morning from our daughter to get her
first acceptance letter for college
so there's some timing yeah yeah yeah
wow we got to write those check I mean
we get to write those checks now it's
excitement with zeros on the end that's
all exactly opportunity opportunities so
Chris what do you do at U-Haul I'm on
markeing company president so I oversee
the region of all the U-Hauls in our
district that I work in I got you okay
cool and you've been there 23 years how
many team members do U-Haul have total
um I believe about 40,000 okay yeah
pretty substantial company to say the
least I mean we all think of it as the
truck or the trailer from the consumer
Viewpoint right but it's a big dad gum
company yeah so as a leader then 23
years in that company you've now
personally experienced this you're able
to concentrate on work cuz you don't
have
271 $91,000 worth of debt hanging over
you and you're now congruent with with
your spouse you're working together MH
instead of her doing it by herself right
and then you trying to figure out what's
happening and um and her wishing you
would have helped and all that stuff
right so now so you see the benefit
personally uh but I'm I'm curious
because I don't get to ask this very
often
um sometimes when I'm doing something in
leadership I personally get to
experience it like you have but I also
immediately see if the person Downstream
does it how it's going to benefit them
and benefit the company right because
they actually think do you see that the
stuff we've been talking about with
productivity and I some of the team
members getting their getting their
lives back yeah CU we're able to focus
more on what we're doing at work versus
at home um I'm able to talk to my staff
on different things with my team on ways
that they can better their personal life
because you get to know all of your team
members and get to know about their
family kind of their financial if
they're talking about going to buy a car
or I got to leave early I got to go do a
refinance or I got to pick up a second
job that kind of thing yeah at least you
got a place to go to discuss it yeah way
to go you guys we're proud of you thank
you very cool and uh our salute to the
U-Haul leadership team for letting
wonderful people like Chris and Jessica
go through smart dollar and paying off
$291,000 in debt count it down let's
hear a debt free Scream 3 2 1 we're Deb
[Applause]
free got to love it baby this is the
ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at Triple H
8255 225 Nick is in Greenville South
Carolina hi Nick welcome to the Ramsey
Show Hey sir thank you for having me
sure what's
up so um I am curious how I should go
about um starting to tackle a small
student loan Mountain um when I'm on
about 3,000 a month and after expenses I
have about
900 spare um so the student loans just
started my first payments last month um
wanting to know should I um do the
Snowballs should I tackle it with an
avalanche method um and how to go about
doing this all the while properly
preparing for a tax season because I'm
an independent
contractor cool What's the total student
loan debt that you
have um right around
33,000 what do you
do I am a Uber driver I am in my college
town I just recently graduated with my
bachelors and I'm sticking around the
area graduated Bachelor's in
what um psychology I'll be applying for
a master's for uh clinical
counseling um and that hopefully if I
get in that'll start August how are you
gonna pay for
that um I thankfully on the GI bill um I
got most of my bachelors well all of my
bachelor paid with the GI Bill the uh
33,000 was pretty much living expenses
over um four years due to cost of living
and not focusing on uh working and um
I'll be able to have 18 months out of my
two-year program for my masters still
covered under the GI bill due to how I
um did my schooling and I will have to
do one semester out of uh more student
loans
okay all right Nick um you're you're new
to the whole ramsy thing um I know this
sir yeah yeah I know this by the
questions you're asking and the
statements you're making um so what I
discovered and we have discovered years
ago is the fastest way to financial
peace peace in your finances the fastest
way to
wealth is to avoid debt at all
cost because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your
income and when you commit it all to
Sally freaking may you um you destroy
your peace and that's why you're calling
us because you're don't have peace right
now now when you restart well the
student loans go back on
deferral I'm assuming so yes as long as
I am an active student yeah I think so
too and so um so what that tells me is
the first thing we're going to talk
about is how you can get your income up
so you can cover future living expenses
and keep it up and no whining just
work okay you're just going to have to
work my man and uh because otherwise
you're going to create another mountain
of student loan debt because you didn't
work so you're going to have to work
while you work on your Masters oh well
by the way almost everyone had a job
when they were in college almost
everyone worked when they were in
college some were smarter about it and
made more than others but almost
everyone that went to college worked I
did I worked 40 to 60 hours a week when
I was in school okay back when the
dinosaurs roamed the Earth but um but
anyway so nothing wrong with working you
can work and you can do a a master's
degree in Psychology and I no no problem
with your goal you're going to need the
Masters to get license if you're going
to move into therapy if you're going to
move into counseling in most States
including South Carolina so you're going
to have to get the Masters it's
permission to play it's table Stakes so
you know go ahead and do that let the GI
pay for it and by the way thank you for
your service in order to get the GI as a
taxpayer I'm more than happy to pay for
your school in return is a way of saying
thank you so you go do that but by God
get your tail in and gear and pay for
cash for that last semester that you're
talking about that's hanging out there
that dangling semester and by God get
enough money in that you have baloney in
the house and you have baloney
sandwiches if not you eat a wish
sandwich two pieces of bread and wish I
had some meat okay we're just going to
do whatever it takes to get through this
with no debt you following me you
following my intensity here yes sir okay
because debt is a behavior thing you
kind of outlined that a little bit in
your process so your first goal right
now is kind of a physician's goal do no
more harm
your first goal is finish your Masters
no more debt that's more I do I do think
I started that Pro in the the first step
to that I am in a debt consolidation
program um and so that's two two of my
credit cards have have already been cut
up and no longer being used yeah okay so
the the the point being we're going to
live on what we make and then step two
step one is no more debt finish the
Masters right with me if we can find any
more money above that and we want to
start reducing debt then we would use
the debt snowball not the debt
Avalanche the reason is the debt
Avalanche normally doesn't
work
because you're in Psychology it's a
feedback loop okay when you pay off the
smallest debt it encourages you it's
like going on a diet and I lost weight
the Avalanche is I go on a diet and I
gain three lbs the first
week I'm getting no traction I get no
positive feedback loop to encourage me
emotionally to in to stay engaged in a
difficult Behavior
change yes sir it's the rat pushing the
lever needs some freaking cheese hello
well that's all we are and so the the
reason the that snowball works is
feedback loop it's not the math it's
it's mathematically incorrect because
we're paying it off smallest balance to
largest balance regardless of the
interest rate but the difference is
mathematically it has a much higher
probability of
completion and the dead Avalanche has an
almost zero probability complet of
completion because there's no feedback
issue there's no feedback loop and so
the feedback is so long that no one
stays engaged and so the mathematical
probability of completion goes down so
overall technically speaking if you want
to get really nerdy about the math when
you build in probability of completion
the debt snowball is actually
mathematically more correct than the
Avalanche but you know we now I'm
getting real nerdy on you so
intellectual but yeah Dave's right I had
a very similar situation to you Nick I
was $36,000 in debt 10 years ago in my
student loans and I thought
intellectually well makes sense to do
the highest interest first when I broke
them all down and it turns out when I
started using that dead snowball method
I actually got this little thing called
hope if I can knock one out I can knock
the next one out it's a little bigger I
can knock the next one out it's a little
bigger I start freeing up these payments
they start making traction and 18 months
later I was debt free I don't know that
I'd be saying the same thing today if I
had used the Avalanche method yeah and
George even paid off his home that's
into your future down there Nick but um
so I I think what needs to happen is you
know what we win at in life is the
things we concentrate on if we're going
to if we want to run a half marathon we
have to concentrate on the training to
prepare to do that if you want to
graduate without any more debt you have
to concentrate on that and that involves
keeping your outgo down and your income
up and these are the things we're
concentrating on after this discussion
today that you and George and I have had
and so that that would be our thing work
the de snowball but truthfully I don't
expect you to make a lot of progress on
it in the next two years because your
main focus is for Nick to graduate with
no more debt of any kind
and live on you know make enough money
to live on and finish that last dangling
semester on the end there the dangling
semester I like that could be like a
Blog but yeah but the uh uh yeah that
that that you can do this Nick I tell
you what we're going to send you a copy
of the book The Total Money
Makeover uh which is my best selling
book ever it's about 10 million copies
out there it'll show you exactly how to
do what we're talking about and you can
play through and do this but part of it
is just making that paradigm shift and
going I'm gonna try a proven plan
instead of trying to intellect my way
out of this that's huge when you can
just commit to a process yeah it it's um
you know Behavior follows
belief and belief does come from a
feedback loop belief is Hope right and
so I have to believe it's going to work
and then I'll engage in the sacrifice in
order to win and Nick I know and I want
you to believe that you can do what we
just told you to do this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's
also the co-host of smart money happy
hour and the host of the vastly popular
YouTube channel the George camel with a
k k a m- l Channel and it's full of
snark and fun and humor and basic uh
really good knowledge that helps you
attack everything out there in the money
space that where people are telling you
lies to get your money we're announcing
today George brand new book Breaking
Free from broke the Ultimate Guide to
more money and less stress it is on
pre-sale starting today uh the book will
actually Pub on January the 16th which
means that's when we'll mail it to you
in the meantime we're going to have it
here for sale and uh that includes a
whole bunch of goodies whenever you buy
the book now or later you'll find a QR
code or six internal that'll help you uh
sign up for a free thre Monon run on
every dollar premium that does the bank
connectivity and does the whole deal
that's a nice value in and of itself and
um that makes the book worth purchasing
if you pre-purchase it of course that's
included you're also going to get
instant access to Georgia's newest talk
show me the money exclusive access this
fall Before Christmas to an online
private event including a Q&A with
George uh we're talking about uh an
online financial event helping you with
your money uh includes the audio book
and the ebook which will come out in
January simultaneous with the book
George congratulations thank you I'm
pumped on this it's you know I've been
working on it for a year now and so it's
weird to now be able to talk about it
publicly but this is a 10 years of
working here at Ramsey trying to help
people avoid some of the myths traps out
there and the gap between Financial
stress and financial piece is littered
with those as you know so I'm trying to
clear the noise Make it simple make it
fun this is every everything you wish
you learned about money but never did
and uh I'm the team has done such a
great job with it and well you've done I
mean the research is airtight and the
humor and the snark uh destroying some
of this Tick Tock stuff that's going on
out there the cryptocurrency garbage the
uh whole life garbage that's come back
the nothing down real estate stuff
that's come back uh the idea that you
know you're going to get rich with
credit card airline miles and all this
stuff you go through line by line by
line by line by line and help people
break free from being broke and you
address every one of the the lies that
are out there in this toxic money
culture oh yeah every objection every
myth and I try to do the onetwo punch
with a lot of research and a lot of
humor and of course some empathy to go I
understand it feels like it's harder
than ever to get ahead with money but
you can break free from broke in 2023
and 2024 yeah so for you Millennials and
J Z's the cool kids are now here and
they'll be here to help you I've never
been the cool kid but according now
you're officially the cool kid Dave has
kned me the cool kid well I mean the the
thing is you're being measured against
me which being the cool kid is a very
low bar so um I appreciate that showing
up beside me you just need to be a kid I
got to hang out with Dave Mo really
helps my
brand Mark is in Toledo hey Mark welcome
to the Ramsey Show hey Dave thanks for
having me sure what's up so me and my
fiance were in a bit of a situation she
took her car to get oil changed at one
of those uh instant oil change places
and they didn't put enough oil in the
car so she left and she drove it and
then started having some problems took
it back there and they topped it off of
oil she drove it a little bit more and
the engine blew up so we took it we had
it towed to a shop the shop said it was
due to lack of oil they said contact
your insurance contact bubling and file
a claim our insurance company denied the
claim because they said it was because
of Maintenance lack of Maintenance lack
of Valene is what it was
yeah and Valene is saying they did
everything right and they put enough oil
in the car so now we have
a $122,000 on and it's sitting at a shop
and it needs a $10,000 engine and both
of our insurances are saying it's not
our
fault well it's not your insurance you
don't have insurance for blown engines
there's no such thing so uh it but it is
Vine's problem Ian you have a legal
problem yes yeah have you contacted an
attorney yeah I have yeah my friend's an
attorney and he's in the car industry is
an attorney and he's saying if you can't
really prove it you might be kind of out
of luck so I have I've reached you you
need a different
lawyer than your
friend okay because um there there's
there's two issues involved with the
strategy here issue number one is being
able to prove it but uh we have a
consumer here that says veline didn't
put vene oil in the car and it blew up
it's pretty simple equation there's
nothing wrong with a car prior of that
day the the uh uh the mechanic has G the
expert has said the car blew up because
it didn't have enough oil right after
you went to the oil place okay this is
not that difficult an equation
right that's what I thought okay from a
legal perspective it's not okay so now
vene has to decide if they want to spend
$25,000 in legal
fees because you're going after their
throat or if they want to just fix the
car which is what they should
do and the way they decide that is you
sue their
butt and then they look and go oh this
guy's serious so what you need to do is
call the uh the store manager I assume
you've already had a discussion or six
with
him yes okay and say I need your legal
department for my attorney to get in
touch with because I'm getting ready to
sue you personally I'm going to sue the
guy who didn't put the plug in
personally I'm going to sue the store in
the franchisee personally and I've
already trashed vene in front of 22
million people on the Ramsey
show and this is going to get worse for
you
guys okay because I mean what you're
describing you're not calling up like
some drama queen and you're not you're
not acting all crazy you're just
describing a you know a $10 an hour guy
and put the stinking oil plug back in
hello well well and it's they're saying
their guns were calibrated and they have
it on video that the oil got put in
there
but there it magic did you use the
disappearing oil I didn't know you had
that when I took it back the guy put
more oil in the car yeah how's that
possible if it was the proper amount it
would have been spilling out through the
manifold and blowing out through the
muffler when you overfill a car with
oil M it didn't blow up from too much
oil what type of attorney should I look
for mean or how do I go about finding
mean and
angry okay yeah I'm serious because
here's what's going to happen what I'm
describing to you is you are going to
become a larger hassle to them than they
want to deal with and so they're going
to fix the car the squeaky wheel gets
the grease or the oil in this case I
don't think we need any more oil I think
we've had quite enough of oil in this
case but yeah yeah you need to get
someone that's going to get all up in
their stuff and say listen we're going
to sue you and we're going to make a
spectacle of you and these corporations
cave like yesterday's minute uh oh my
God and it's just that they're going to
write a chat that's what needs to happen
you need to get your dad gun money out
of cuz what you're describing is a very
clear
[Music]
case hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
Plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
5225 Jacob is in Fort Worth Texas hi
Jacob how are
you oh well Dave thanks for taking my
call doing very well good how can we
help
today so my question for you
is if going back to school to pursue my
bachelor's is a smart use of my
time do you have any degrees
currently I do so long story short um
I'm in Performing Arts fulltime and my
associates is in recording student
engineering which I got off of tuition
way
academic merit scholarship and Co grants
during the
pandemic and so I was able to graduate
without a diamond student did great and
so this particular opportunity has come
up to where I can pursue my Bachelor's
in music business with some pretty
generous discounts and some other
incentives that would allow me to go
through the entire duration
part-time and my
entire Financial Obligations will
probably come out to about maybe 3,000
total what are you changing horses
for well I guess what it is is
that is that you know I you know I work
full-time but I also have four part-time
jobs on top of that so I you work you
work you work full-time as what what do
you
do I'm a production manager and an audio
engineer and recording engineer for
performing art
organization and I also have four other
part-time jobs in related fields for fun
or are you trying to earn some extra
income so the part-time jobs are for
extra income but there's also a lot of
personal fulfillment to it okay so
remind me again what you just said your
current degree was
in uh my current degree is in recording
student engineering oh okay okay so are
you wanting to do something totally
different no just music business he's
want to get in the music side instead of
the or the business
side right so yes yes so so so the big
so the big thing is that is being able
to extend and Advance my career
essentially and to BR my knowledge on
the music business part of it and and I
come also come from a background of
doing Commercial Real Estate Management
and after getting light off it was my
wife actually told me to go back to
college to study something that I know
that I'd like and so I chose recording
student engineering and I've been busy
non-stop ever since and yes I put in a
lot of long hours but I've never been
any less stressed and it's never been a
stressful job doing what I
do I'm just worried this isn't going to
give you what you want you get on the
other side of this and you have a degree
and you were able to pay for it but it's
not anywhere closer to what you want to
do because we got a lot of music
business degrees that work here at
Ramsey Solutions and we don't have a
music department
so I tell you that to say it's not going
to just magically give you this perfect
dream job in music business just because
you have the degree will is
relationships and networking and those
kinds of opportunities yeah if you can
do if you have done commercial real
estate deals in the past and you can do
audio engineering um you don't need a
music business degree to do business in
music it's not it's not it's not
permission to play they're not going to
teach you anything in that degree that's
going to be Earth shatteringly
different the business principles that
you are already aware of function in the
music business as well and um the
business of music so to speak so uh you
know if you're coming out of school as a
kid and you're 22 and you want to go
into the music the business side of the
music business uh than a music business
degree might be but a business degree
also would just do it you don't have to
know anything about music music um you
just got to be able to do business and I
mean so uh um and the thing is you don't
get joy from that anyway what you get
joy from is actually producing
right yeah and you don't you don't need
a music business degree to grow your
production
career so no I wouldn't do it okay
that's fair I wouldn't do it uh I
because I don't think what you do need
is you do need and what you're willing
to engage in is to increase your
knowledge base but a degree is not
necessary if you want to go audit some
classes on accounting and marketing and
you want to take a few business if
there's a local curriculum that has a
music
business uh actual subject matter and
you want to take a couple of those
classes that's fine but that's far
different than engaging in a full degree
program and not NE and that's all it's
necessary you in other words put some
tools in your belt that you don't have
in your belt now that enable you to take
those next steps but the sheep skin the
actual degree itself is not is not the
door it's not the door opener the
knowledge is the door
opener does that see you see the
difference does make sense yeah like
five classes instead of
30 is the
difference a a and even in those classes
you're not going to learn everything you
need some of it you're just going to get
your foot in the door and you're going
to learn and be mentored by whoever's
leading you in that particular area but
I don't sense that you're wanting to run
a record record
label no and it's and you know a big
part of it is to you advance my
knowledge in the music part of it and
that and you know and the organization I
also work for is also offering that if I
do my Pursuits then they'll also
underwrite any additional expenses that
may be incurred with it yeah but just
because it's free doesn't mean you need
to invest your time to do
it all right I think you need to have a
a clear goal for what the career and job
is not for what the degree is and then
then search out on knowledge that's
necessary for that I mean we happen to
be in Nashville as George said I grew up
in Nashville um I've got several very
close friends that own and run record
labels and have built and have sold them
and I you know that business I'm afraid
I know more about it than I want to know
and uh and and I just I don't run into
people running around there they go you
know I wouldn't let somebody come to
work at my record label in the
leadership team because they didn't have
music business degree zero times have I
heard something like zero it's more like
can they get the crap done you know it's
like any other small business
Arrangement and so can you actually be
effective and if you need some more
knowledge to be effective get the
knowledge but do not take the time out
of your life to go collect more degrees
that's not going to make your life
better I wouldn't do it thanks for the
call open phone at 8825 5225 Joseph's in
Grand Rapids hi Joseph how are you hey
guys uh thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up so um we uh are
about 11 weeks pregnant with our second
[Applause]
child um George didn't get any sleep
last night either
exhausted uh we've only been doing the
baby steps a couple months I know that
you're supposed to stop baby step 2 and
um you start saving up but I was just
wondering um when should I start saving
and like how much is it like a specific
goal and when to restart the baby steps
all you can in the next eight
months or seven months in your
case okay right and because here's the
thing if you let's how much could you
save if you went crazy like 10,000
bucks uh 20,000 bucks
yeah meet you in the middle at 15 okay
all right so if you stack up 15,000
instead of paying down debt by
15,000 7 months from today mommy and
baby come home from the hospital you
write $115,000 worth of checks and pay
off the $115,000 worth of debt that you
would have paid off during this s months
otherwise you follow me m yeah what is
what did you lose the interest on that
debt during that time right that's all
and what did you gain huge pile of money
and peace of mind while baby's on the
way
sure that's why we say to do it that
that's our
reasoning it's that simple fair enough
yeah all right so yeah so it's not like
a specific goal it's just peace of mind
and just adjust in case in I'm G Turn
Around drain every dime of it but a th
as soon as mom and baby come home from
the hospital healthy and at the minimum
you want the out- of- pocket max for
your insurance cuz you're definitely
going to be paying that out over the
next eight
months congratulations sir happy for you
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
well you've all played the telephone
game the the first person Whispers a
message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data net Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for Ramsay and it will make
a difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America if you didn't know money
problems are the number one thing that
caused divorce in America today money
problems are the number one stress point
of the team that you work with at your
workplace and if it's a if your personal
money problems are a stress point
meaning MasterCard is bothering you
you're worried about your car being
repoed you had a big fight with your
spouse about money uh that means when
you're at work you're thinking about
that stuff instead of work which is a
productivity issue hello so lots of
great companies around America have
decided to address that uh we coined the
phrase a decade and a half ago called
Financial wellness and now Financial
Wellness is quite the craze in the HR
world uh to help their team get
financial Wellness we have a product
called smart dollar where companies buy
our curriculum to teach their teams how
to handle money they furnish it to them
as an HR benefit and lots of great
companies Across America have done that
many many big ones and many many many
many many small ones and so we're
thankful for that uh because what
happens is when the team goes through
this they're less stressed about money
and their productivity goes up they're
concentrating on work at work one of the
great companies that does that is is
U-Haul U-Haul if you didn't know is a
massively large company It's a Wonderful
company we've done a lot of business
with them for a lot of years and uh so
today we're kind of having a U-Haul day
around Ramsey because we got a lot of
the U-Haul team members coming in to do
their debt-free Scream because they've
been teaching smart dollar for many many
months now and years for that matter so
over $6.7 million in debt paid and
dollars saved within that one company
due to the company uh Furnishing this as
a benefit to their team Financial
Wellness with smart Dollar on the debt
free stage are Gary and Teresa Good Old
you Hall team members hey guys how are
you doing great Dave how are you better
than I deserve now where do y'all live
Phoenix Arizona so you would be in the
home office yes sir okay very cool very
cool and uh which one of you working for
you Hall that would be me that would be
you Gary how long have you been there
going on 15 years wow longtime team
member excellent job job okay how much
debt have you paid off $37,500
mhm and that was uh a car and a credit
card very good how long did that take
about 28 months good for you okay what
do you do at U-Haul I'm a business
analyst with our ubox which is uh
shipping containers that are dropped at
your house you load them up at your
leisure we pick them up and then we'll
deliver them from point A to point B
we'll store them whatever you want ah
gotcha good ad well done I'm sold
George George is ordering one right now
and he's not even moving I don't even
need it sounds great okay fun so uh
that's cool uh how long you guys been
married this is our second marriage
we're a blended family we're going on 19
years wow and one of the things that we
when we first got married we wanted to
keep open our finances together and we
got introduced to uh Financial Peace
University and then when smart dollar
came to U-Haul uh I just became a
champion and a cheerleader for it ah
very cool so Teresa when this showed up
at his work you already knew about all
of it right I knew about it and I knew
what we had done in the past with
Financial Peace University as well so
that was another so that's why it was
only 38,000 you'd fallen off the wagon a
little and just had a little cleanup to
do exactly I uh on the advice of councel
I'd like to plead the
fifth yes she counseled you not to put
your foot your
mouth exactly exactly and that's what it
is and you know we just got back on it
and every company needs to have Smart
dollar uh it just is phenomenal the
people at U-Haul that have embraced it
you know now I have somebody came to me
the other day and they said I can
breathe
now it's just absolutely wonderful and
Teresa you know when I was talking with
her she just said uh it's so exciting
and the way it's set up it's so easy to
follow yeah so Teresa did you go back
through the smart dollar thing after
when he started doing it at work um a
little bit okay all right cool so y all
worked on it together again but it just
brought it it just brought it back to
for you guys it was a review yes more
than an introduction okay oh yeah very
good and also different partners with it
you know trying to go through it before
when I was by myself after my first
marriage oh you weren't married when you
did before um I was married the first I
me you two weren't married when finies
together okay okay so that yeah that
makes a lot of sense then that's a whole
new set of eyes to look at it now yeah
absolutely yeah very cool that's amazing
I'm curious you know a lot of people say
wellit hey that's that's personal stuff
leave that at home you got to be at work
but what you're saying is you can't
really because when you get to work and
you're stressed cuz your car broke down
and you don't have the repairs to make
it all you're complaining about in the
break room is this car and this money
problem and so to show up at work and
not have that and everyone's on champing
in each other together that's an amazing
feeling oh absolutely and to piggy back
on that now when we have to replace
tires or something goes out it's not an
emergency it's a
inconvenience right that's huge and that
makes a big difference that's how it's
supposed to work what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
budgeting spend list and what you make
budget persevere persevere push on
through push on through they're all
connected exactly absolutely well done
too I'm proud of you great work very
very cool so you've seen a difference in
some of your co-workers as well then oh
absolutely absolutely every company
should get this smart dollar it it just
it makes the difference because people
see I can do this I can live it and then
at the end of the day like George said
I'm not thinking about how am I going to
pay my minimum payment and I'm going to
have to get a cash advance and what am I
going to do and then how am I going to
go home and face my wife you know I
think U-Haul has Gary in the wrong seat
as a business analyst he's quite a pitch
man I'm impressed you got to move you to
sales he's selling U-Haul and he's
selling smart I mean I'm buying
everything he's selling I'm just saying
this guy's he's got it lined up here way
to go man thank you thank you very much
we appreciate that and I appreciate the
endorsement and all kidding aside um
we're thrilled with uh with being with
partnering with you guys you're a great
American company and I'm thrilled that
on an individual basis that uh you guys
are uh able to win and uh take this new
step in your uh second marriage here and
you know have a whole different level of
peace and and unity there that's very
cool we're proud for you thank you
excellent can we make one shout out to
the grandkids they're the best in the
world sorry Dave uh but our grand kid
our grandkids Charlotte and Ensley
that's just you know we would have been
much nicer to their parents to borrow a
your line you know if I have known how
great gr and kids are going to be I'd
have been nicer to their parents oh
absolutely yeah we're getting ready to
keep uh keep the smallest one over the
weekend so um we're bracing ourselves
and so is he prayers for you prayers
lots of prayers be a battle hey fun it's
a battle I will win so way to go Gary
and Teresa and you hul gang excellent
excellent job
$38,000 paid off in 28 months it was a
review it was a real uh process to
restart and uh to to reinvigorate some
things in their lives way to go guys
count it down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 we're debt
free that's how it's
done well played well played well played
the smart dollar team is beaming with
pride cuz they get to see the impact
they they're making every day when they
get to meet these people absolutely
awesome yeah and and you know U-Haul's
got like
40,000 team members it's a huge hurt my
brain Costco had all of their team go
through it as well so we've had a lot of
big companies like those guys National
you know American brands that everyone
knows and then we've had a lot of
companies that you never heard of that
are small with and pop business 100 team
members or 50 team members or 300 team
members or a th000 team members they're
not all 40,000 you know and and so
that's
uh it's something we don't get to talk
about here on the air a lot so I'm glad
we're bragging on them today oh yeah and
hey nag your HR team and tell them hey I
want smart dollar make it happen you can
go check them out at ramsy solutions.com
smartdollar or bypass the HR people and
just go to the leaders ooh that's a move
right there boom power move Dave said I
could power move this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Lisa is in Frederickburg
Virginia hi Lisa how are
you hi Dave it's a pleasure to speak
with you you too how can we
help um so I have a pretty complex um
question and I I've heard your last um
segment previously about shacking up and
sharing finances and things like that
you're not married so please don't chew
me out as a as a
disclaimer um I co-signed um for my
boyfriend for a car um he owes about
32,000 or I should say we ow about
32,000 and he's been behind on the
payment um I've been denied for two
personal loans um for the difference of
the vehicle um due to my debt to income
ratio so I'm really trying to figure out
how to get from under this car um
completely and uh is this your
ex-boyfriend no Cent oh
okay well it sounds like he can't afford
the
car yeah it sounds like a couldn't
afford it when you got has got the loan
considering he needed a cosigner and he
hadn't paid the
payments yes what's the car worth so why
is he not selling the
car he can't afford it and he's doing
damage to his girlfriend there's two
reasons to get rid of the
car yeah so the the private sale um
based on Kelly Blue Book was 19,000
tradeing value is 17,000 um like said we
owe 32,000 so that balance that
difference there don't have the money
saved up for that difference or I'm not
able to get a personal loan um to even
cover
that um I went to two credit unions my
personal Credit Union and then the
credit union that the cars financed
through but they said my debt to income
ratio was just too high in order to
approve the Lo the credit union that
your car is going through is
confused uh you and boyfriend need to go
sit down with that credit union and talk
to the manager and here's how it sounds
okay
Mr
manager you have a
$119,000 car loan and a
$133,000 personal loan because you have
a
$32,000 car loan that only has $19,000
worth of collateral so you're unsecured
right now for $ 13,000 if you have to
take the car back and repo it you're
going to be unsecured for even more than
that
this is you telling the manager this you
following
me yes and so I asking you to allow us
to sign a note for the
difference the amount that the car won't
bring gets the strain off of your bad
loan off of him my boyfriend and all
you're doing is admitting that this loan
is only partially
collateralized he already doesn't have a
collateralized loan cuz the car is
upside down 13k you follow me yes just
explain that to him sometimes you have
to say that out loud because sometimes a
credit union manager hasn't thought this
through and if they thought it through
then they would go oh I have a much
higher likelihood of getting my
$113,000 amount that were upside down if
I let this guy out of the
19 by selling the
car cuz the 13 is not collateral anyway
then you we've reduced your problem to a
$113,000 problem and then you and said
boyfriend take six jobs and pay off the
13,000 before you pay off anything
else and never sign a loan again with
someone you're not married
to see I didn't yell did I I did good
was very kind calm Dave thank you thank
you it was almost story time it's so
relaxing does that make sense to you
Lisa you I mean that's the only way I
know to get you out other than you guys
both go work 6080 hours a week and come
up with
13k yeah okay I'll I'll try that yeah he
can't keep the
car and and you guys have not had this
discussion and he's being a little boy
and hasn't admitted it yet he's doing
harm to the person he claims to
love you
yeah because he can't pay the
bill we know that because he hasn't been
paying the bill and it's messed up your
credit am am I missing
something no no what does he make a
year um he makes about 55 yeah, yeah so
the car was a bad purchase
anyway buying buying a $32,000 car when
you make 55 is not is out of line even
if you pay cash for it that was just did
you guys put anything down on this or
was this no no no nothing down with a
cosigner rolled negative equity from the
deal before into it didn't you yes
that's right yeah that's why you're in
13 upside down already yeah that
explains it there's no way You' be that
far in the hole otherwise oh unless it
was the world's worst car but yeah um
what kind of car is
it it's a 2021 Honda Elantra okay nice
car yeah okay so where's his head on
this Lisa what's he going
say um so we've actually both been
trying to get rid of it he's on board
with getting rid of it but yeah he's not
able to do much um he's relying on me
because I have the the better credit to
yeah you used to before he came along
yeah well it hasn't been reported yet um
but he's been behind and I'm just afraid
that it is going to start being reported
and then it's going to tank both of our
credit scores yeah yeah well it's going
to for sure and um
in the meantime what you've got is a
high debt to income ratio which is
keeping you from getting the other loans
right yes that's not the damage it's not
damage credit that you got out the debt
so what do you
make um 60 okay you got $15,000 income
between the two of
you I think we need to cut down to beans
and rice rice and beans and take two
more extra jobs and sell everything in
sight and get these messes cleaned up if
I were in you guys shoes that's what I
would do but this is just this horrible
experience for you and for him for that
matter has been y all's wakeup call we
just made a mistake and uh Lisa if if if
you were the only person who ever made a
mistake about a car or co-signing for a
car in America we George and I wouldn't
have a job thank you for job SEC it's
like the largest mistake people make in
George well I hope listeners are going
oh that's why I shouldn't coign because
a lot of people think I'm doing them a
favor I love this person and then they
get themselves in a pickle and it
damages the relationship yeah and their
own Financial world you know the worst
one is something that's in this case
Lisa's boyfriend is being fairly mature
and is already saying hey yeah we got to
I'm going to help we got to get rid of
this car how do we do this he's
depending on her to get the money but um
but he was before but he's at least he's
not saying no I don't want to sell my
car thank God I was afraid he was going
to be that guy whiny toddler but yeah
but the uh the worst one was like the
grandpa co-signs for the the 21-year-old
grandson's pickup truck oh gosh and now
they can't find Junior just took off
disappeared and doesn't pay the bill and
Grandpa's now on the hook for the whole
puppy cuz they can't even find the truck
to repo it and Grandpa was probably
broke to begin with and brokenhearted
cuz it's his grandson you know this is
the stuff we deal with every day around
here and the holidays get real awkward
yeah well ain't awkward for him cuz the
kid's gone we can't find him but you
know gosh it's just uh that you know but
the problem is he'll never come back to
his grandpa because of Shame mhm even if
the grandpa forgives him it doesn't
matter at that he he's it's a prodal
it's a you know he has to wake up in the
pig sty to come home now but the shame
to come back and so he's lost his
relationship with his grandfather that's
sad that's priceless that's what happens
a lot with these things and so Proverbs
17:18 says one lacking in sense signs
alone for
another the new contemporary English
version says it is stupid to
cosign I like that version it's pretty
plain I've cosigned before by the way
Lisa has co-signed before I got to pay
it one guy co-signed for me when I went
into bankruptcy he got to pay it and I
had to go back and pay him back later
but his wife's still pissed and the
assumption is that well I'll never pay
they'll be good they'll be able to make
the payments I just helped him get the
loan yeah but of course that's wrong or
they wouldn't have required a co-signer
you know they require a co-signer
because we couldn't pay and lender says
you're going to take the risk not us
exactly that's I was not credit worthy
at the time the guy co-signed for me and
guess what we proved it you you know I
mean oh it's just awful it's a horrible
thing but it's it's one of those
codependent things where we feel like
we're doing something nice and you're
doing a nice thing in a wrong way that
becomes hurtful rather than a
blessing that puts us hour the Ramsey
Show in the
[Music]
[Applause]
books
[Music]
a
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for joining us
America George camel Ramsey personality
co-host of the smart money happppy Hour
podcast with Rachel Cruz and host of The
George camel YouTube channel is my
co-host today and today we are
announcing the pre-sale of his first
book Breaking Free from broke the book
will come out in January and on January
16th to be precise and uh pre-order
starts today you get $100 in free bonus
items includes the audio book the uh the
ebook that you'll get at the time but
guess what if you order now uh you also
will get today a copy of instant access
to his newest talk show me the money and
exclusive access to an Online private
event with George talking about the
money issues and a Q&A with George as
well and we haven't announced the date
on the Online private event yet right no
no specific date yet we're working on
that but it's going to be big you have
to pre-order to be in signed up for that
and that's part of the package over $100
worth now whenever you buy the book
inside the book are some QR codes that
allow you to get three months of every
dollar the premium version with all the
sweet features Bank connectivity
paycheck planning you name it so we
wanted that because it takes 90 days for
people to get a budget and it's a key to
Breaking Free from broke so we thought
let's just give it to them so George
when I read the book uh going over the
manuscript to approve the thing as as a
CEO of the company um which I do I
obviously read our books before we put
them out from all of you guys all you
Ramsey personalities um the thing I came
back to you with was that it's extremely
well researched it's fun it's funny it's
really snarky which I totally loved um
and it kind of made me feel like it was
like you know I wrote financial piece in
1992 wow and you know we've done some
revised versions of it after that uh we
published it with a publisher after
coming out of the self-published world
in those days in 1996 it was a
bestseller uh and so four years later
adding chapters to it and polishing it
up and getting a professional publisher
to help me do it in those days I didn't
know what the flip I was doing but you
know so so but a lot of the information
in your book is things that didn't exist
in 1992 like you address crypto uh but
it's some things that did exist then
that we're still struggling with credit
card debt car debt uh the toxic things
the lies that people believe in the
culture but you did it in such a way
that
um I really think there's going to be a
whole lot of people between 22 and 52
that're going to love this book I think
some older ones like it too yeah but
especially if you're like me and you
like snark you'll love it but um but you
know it's a lot it's like Financial
Peace for this generation I appreciate
that it's very kind and I did try you
know the first two-thirds of the book
I'm really unpacking this broken
Financial system and all the lies that
we were sold and how we got there and
you're right the problems are different
today Dave they go to Dave and they go
well Dave doesn't understand because
when he grew up houses were $30,000 now
they're for and I try to just be the
middleman between you two between the
audience and Dave going I get it I
understand here's what we can do about
it because the times have changed it
feels harder than ever to get ahead
financially but I'm telling you this the
principles still work to this day the
baby steps still work if you don't screw
it up and I show you how to break free
from that system that we've been chained
to with our American consumerism and I
hope it's a plan that helps millions of
people I think I think it's going to
Breaking Free from broke the Ultimate
Guide to more money money and less
stress on pre-sale starting today at
Ramsey solutions.com jump in the store
get all of the goodies that will support
George support the marketing efforts for
the book Thank you very very much
Marissa Is With Us in Atlanta Hi Marissa
welcome to the Ramsey
Show Hi how are you great what's
up um so my question is uh with the
student loan repayments starting uh my
parents and I like many others are a
little overwhelmed trying to figure out
our approach um so when we took out
loans for my school my parents didn't
have great credit and I didn't have a
line of credit so they took out a plus
loan and I'm the third kid that went to
school in our family so they have Plus
loans for all three of us and then I
have my separate subsidized and
unsubsidized loan under my name my
question is should I have the Parent
PLUS Loan transferred to my name and
refinance it to take the burden off of
my parents um because we're just trying
to figure out the best way to approach
it and right now it's just way too much
for them to
handle if you can pay the payment just
pay the
payment myself or my parents well you
said your parents can't handle it and
you were going to move it to your name
which would mean you're paying the
payment
right yeah I mean I so I graduated two
years ago
um with a health science degree and I
don't make a ton of money right now
where I my original so I I just got a
new job I'm gonna make $23 an hour and
then I also um have like a side nny and
gig as just like a transportation to
school um but my original plan was to
like go to medical school do that whole
thing and then once I graduated I was
overwhelmed already with the amount of
debt that I have how much debt do you
have so under my name I have 27,000 but
then my the parent plus loan is I think
up to like
80,000
okay um well it does no it it does not
add any value to move it to your name
you can't pay
it you don't make
enough you're struggling to pay your 20
am I missing
something I just with my parents having
three kids it just all kind of fell on
them and I think with us being the first
generation college kids we didn't really
know that much going into it um I don't
think that we really did the best
research when we were going into school
to try to find our best option um and
so i i i there's I appreciate you owning
it it's obvious mistakes have been made
yes you got you got $107,000 and student
loan debt and you're making $23 an hour
so obviously mistakes have been made
there's not you know but but that's you
know water under the bridge at this
point if you call me up you said I'm
making 100,000 a year I'm about to knock
this 27 out in a heartbeat and I'm going
to take this 80 over and knock it out
for Mom and Dad uh I would tell you just
to pay it while it's in mom and dad's
name and take the the mathematical
burden off of them but no reason to
legally put it in your name it doesn't
serve any purpose go ahead and knock it
out but in your case you can little
you're going to have to work on your
career side your income side to be able
to address the 27 before we can even
talk about helping with the 80 unless
I'm missing the math am I missing
something no definitely not and that's
been my struggle because with my degree
being so specific with Health Sciences
my goal was to further my education and
go to to PA school um and then I worked
in medical office for about 2 years and
decided that I didn't want to further my
career in it in that
direction um you're going to have to
work on the career side of your equation
I don't think spending six figures on PA
school is to move right now let's clean
up the mess first the answer to your
question is you can't take your parents'
burden you don't have the strength to
[Music]
mathematically
w
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today jeffon Jackson Mississippi
hi Jeff welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey guys how are y'all doing better
than we deserve what's up I heard that
me too I just wanted to call and say I
have some good news me and my wife are
currently out of bit and we own the
house that we're in but some old family
land has uh come available and we want
to get that back it just so happens that
there is a $400,000 house on it so we're
getting ready to jump back into some
debt and get a
mortgage and also prepare for you know
retirement and that kind of thing so um
we want to get the house we definitely
want to get it back and um how would you
advise on maxing out aggressively paying
on the principle of the loan to try to
pay it off you know in like the first 10
years versus maxing out like 401ks and
mutual funds uh the best way to proceed
with what's your current home 20
years um it's my it's an old family
house it's my grandparents house we're
not planning on getting rid of it uh
it's going to stay in the family but
estimation probably 300 300,000 for it
and then it's on a a big block of land
too so what do you make we're try um me
and my wife together about
160,000 before taxes yeah how many more
pieces of family ground that can't be uh
that you can't do without are you're
going to run
into dude you got you got like a you got
like an addiction to family
ground well this is uh where I grew up
and it's one 1.5 Acres out of the
original 40 that my grandparents bought
in 79 and they it got split up
throughout the years and you know they
left it to to me to care for and you
know give it you know on to our kids so
what would be your plan you're not going
to move you're just going to hang on to
it uh buy the new house get the land
back is right there close by and that
would be our primary residence and then
we would keep um the grandparents house
up and either my sister might move into
it or my mother's getting older so she
might move into it to help keep it up
and
possibly sell their house that they're
in there's a lot of variables here and a
lot of mites all right the answer to
your technical question is wherever
you're following the baby steps so
you're getting ready to go back from
baby steps seven and be back in baby
steps four five and six so you're going
to limit retirement to 15% of your
income and any of the money you can find
in your budget you're going to throw at
the debt on the um $400,000 property
okay until you get it paid off early
that that's that's the answer to your
question um and you probably can do that
in 10 or 12 years something like that um
but I got to tell you there's a a
narrative running through your stories
That's not
healthy okay the narrative is and I've
heard it a lot in my life of doing what
I do the narrative is it doesn't matter
what it cost or how stupid it is it's
family land and we have to keep
it that's in that's in your story all
the time and um okay I'm not sure any of
this completely goes over into the
stupid Zone but your uh inability to I
mean 1979 is not exactly Legacy property
on an acre and a
half I mean that's not that's not like
1879 that's
1979 I I understand and it was it was 69
and it would this is is a 40 acre block
originally this is just
one only got and you don't even have the
whole block you've only got an acre and
a half it's not like a big plot of
ground that was the families um so I
mean your your uh need to protect the
family's
Nostalgia uh seems to know no bounds and
that scares me for you cuz it's going to
lead you into some stupid butt decisions
before this is over you you're not quite
there with this the numbers on this
don't scare me it's the U you know it's
the analysis that's scares me uh and
that that's why I'm calling you out on
it just cuz I love you and I want you to
win because I
mean you know there's going to be
another thing come up and then there's
going to the property adjacent to the
acre and a half is going to come
available the old 40 acre track and then
what are you going to do and then
there's going to be another thing come
up and then your sister's living in it
but you own it and it has to stay in the
family and to a dysfunctional level and
and uh it's just real estate it's not
it's not your family's DNA it's just
real estate and so um uh uh I'm
nostalgic and the older I get the more
nostalgic I get about certain P types of
possessions and things that have been in
the family over the years and that kind
of thing I want to hold on to them but
uh real estate is a very tough one to do
that with
um my grandmother inherited from her
grandfather a family farm during her
lifetime she and my grandpa subdivided
the Family Farm sold it off as
subdivision Lots leaving only about a 4
acre track and uh and a old Family Farm
or family Farmhouse that had been in the
family three generations at that point
when she passed away uh my parents'
generation her kids sold it cuz none of
them were going to live in it none of
them lived in the same town they weren't
holding on to it for posterity and so I
I'm not fussing at you Jeff I'm just
saying man the way you're working your
way through this it's um you're setting
yourself up for potential problems yeah
and what if the sister doesn't want to
live there and mom doesn't want to live
there now you're up got this upkeep on
this house that's vacant you don't want
someone to rent it cuz it's precious
family property yeah it it just it's be
careful man be careful you're there's
some there's some thin ice in where
you're skating but the numbers you're
giving me aren't the end of the world I
still think you could do this deal pay
it off in 15 years or less which is our
guidelines so you're not doing anything
that's you know if if you told me the
property is 2 and half million and you
were never going to be able to pay it
off but you had to do it because it was
family then I would just say no you
don't I just say don't but you I think
you can afford to pull this off I hate
to see you go back into debt because you
kept a 1979 piece of property um again
1879 maybe I might get a little bit more
emotional about that but 1979 I mean MC
Jagger was already old in 1979 I mean
that's you know it's not that long ago
so
J Jamie is in Pittsburgh uh I guess yeah
Jamie's in Pittsburgh hi Jamie how are
you I'm doing well hi Dave and George
it's an honor to speak with you um I
wanted to let you know I'm an FPU
coordinator and I had a 77y old recent
widow um and she needs some help finding
hope she had no family so I offered to
help her through it um she lives on
Social Security and a small annuity and
her credit card minimum payments are 50%
of her income plus she has a she had a h
car
salesman uh in the midst of her grief
talk her into getting a new car Le lease
and uh it seems overwhelming and I
wondered if you might advise me on how
to walk through this with
her oh what a sad situation
Jamie yeah um well there's going to be a
lot of
pain yeah because there's a lot of pain
uh there's not anything we can do about
it um there's not a magic wand in this
she's going to be selling the
car and she's probably not going to be
able to pay the credit
cards
right yeah I mean I that's how I was
thinking I I heard one of your first
callers just and you advise them to stop
making the payments she's been making
the minimum payments yeah how how by
putting on other credit cards CU she got
a pay she got a house payment
money does she have a house
payment no she's renting yeah how much
is her
rent uh 720 a month so her credit cards
are way more than her
rent yes by the time she pays her credit
cards and pays her rent she doesn't have
any money for
food yeah so she can't pay the credit
cards doing some like playing piano or
something to make money to buy food
that'd be great except we're going to do
this the other way around the first
thing we buy is food the second thing we
buy is shelter the third thing we buy is
lights and water then we pay what we can
pay and you sell the car immediately the
car's got to go or repo it one of the
two volunteer but she doesn't pay any
more car payments she can't afford this
car they deserve what they get for
selling this lady this
car oh what a mess I'm so sorry
Jamie
[Music]
[Applause]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
225 one of the things we do at Ramsey is
a product called smart dollar we
invented the space called Financial
Wellness Financial wellness.com I own as
an example so this idea that Corporate
America goes and teaches their team
members how to handle money properly so
that they become better team members
because they're better daddies and
better mommies because they have less
stress and they're winning is something
that kind of came out of ramsy and our
process is called smart dollar major
companies All Over America do this and
as a benefit for their team members and
minor companies do this for their team
members people with 100 team members a
th000 team members and in today's case
40,000 team members with a great
American company called U-Haul that's
pretty amazing I think of U-Haul is
really these nice little trucks 40,000
people working there that's a lot of
trucks man it's incredible but it's a
great I mean it's like a it's iconic
it's it's apple pie you know Chevrolet
U-Haul I mean it's it's almost like
Kleenex you know it's like if you're
going to move you say U-Haul right
and so it's it's been in it's been a
part of our vernacular for uh bazillion
decades so we're real thrilled that
U-Haul has had their entire team go
through smart dollar offered it to Smart
dollar uh smart dollar to them and we're
doing debt-free screams with some of
their team today Eric and Elda are up
next to do a U-haul debt free scream
where do you guys live uh Phoenix
Arizona which would be the home office
yes sir awesome what do you do at U-Haul
I'm a project manager okay and Elder
what do you do I work for Arizona State
University in the register's office ah
very cool ASU ASU I love it very cool
well Phoenix is a great town it sounds
like you guys got a great life there
congratulations welcome to Nashville how
much debt did you pay off in smart
dollar sir we did about $100,000 in 36
months good for you all right well since
a lot of your U-Haul friends are
listening and watching and hanging
around uh we're not going to ask you
your income cuz they'll go oh that's
what Eric makes # awward who knew yeah
that'd be weird so we're going to we're
going to let you off the income side of
things but 100,000 bucks in three years
so you're averaging 33,000 a year about
2800 bucks a month going towards this
that's substantial yes it was what kind
of debt was that oh You Name It We were
normal yeah credit card uh student loans
uh some medical um car loans car loans
yeah Furniture we bought Furniture you
know yeah so U-Haul put this in about
three years ago the first time right yes
sir I mean it's still there new new team
members or team members that haven't
done it yet can still do smart dollar
but you jumped in three years ago when
we first did it right we did okay and
and so Elder he comes home from work and
goes hey work's doing this thing I can
hear it right
now uh that that had to be a little
awkward right it was very awkward um I'm
like okay what is it and what are we
doing we like what's going on another HR
benefit yeah I roll yeah only this one
actually is a benefit exactly who knew
it sure is did he do a good job selling
it to you or did you have to take some
time to come around to the idea oh no he
did an an amazing job selling it to me
it I was on board pretty much right away
cuz you felt the money stress and he was
saying hey this is going to help us get
rid of this money stress get rid of the
debt have a better life exactly and
we're not getting any younger so so um
you know and we do have a an 8-year-old
well we have an 11-year-old daughter but
she was eight at the time um and so not
only we did it for ourselves but we did
it for her as well amen that's a good
why right there yeah and you just look
up and you go hey we've been living this
100,000 like having a back ache I can't
get rid of oh it was it was crazy Dave
there was times in our 21y year marriage
we had 12 cents to our name 12 cents and
I was like you know what normal isn't
working for us we have to figure out
something different exactly so what was
it you guys learned in smart dollar that
caused you to be able to pay off
$100,000 in debt what's the key
discipline oh um that sounds dirty yeah
I know it's crazy well he's a Marine cor
Fett so yeah oh you're no stranger to
discipline oh no and it's crazy one of
the things in there don't
spend as as much money as you have like
oh wait a minute you're making XYZ M all
right don't go $10,000 $5,000 over
exactly burn up those credit cards we
actually burned those credit cards up we
actually burned the credit cards burned
them we burned them physically melted
them down it was like burning debt so
instead of cutting them up we're like
all right everyone to the backyard let's
go ahead going to the fire pit in middle
of Phoenix too so it was July and
Phoenix and we're burning stuff in the
pit whoa neighbors the neighbors are
going hey look over there they lost it
neighb lost it neighbor looks
over okay
okay stay away from
Eric Eric's burning stuff in summer in
Phoenix yeah wow I love it way to go
guys that was symbolic for you guys it
was a line a big deal yeah cuz that that
changes the world when you say I'm done
I'm done living like this I'm going to
do a new thing the old thing ain't
working and you're correct it changes
the world but our world specifically
that's what I mean yeah our world cuz
you suddenly don't care what the
neighbor thinks looking over the fence
it's like hey come on over I'll tell you
about it buddy exactly yeah especially
for our 11-year-old daughter Erica yeah
so you know we our parents struggled um
and we didn't want that for ourselves or
for our daughter so um so so it's a
gener generational thing changing the
family tree yeah amazing family tree
yeah that's a big motivator and really
really cool so you're in the office so a
lot of folks in the home office
certainly have done the smart dollar
program they've done it all over the
nation but um have you seen changes with
your other team members I have it brings
it brings
Clarity so before one had this debt I
would see you know this big cloud over
and it would honestly it it would zap my
focus and it zap the focus in the
discipline coming into work now you know
it's Crystal clearage sharp edge m going
in and you see it and for anyone who
hasn't tried it uh who anyone thinks
about doing it what's the worst that can
happen and get out of
dead ter wor get a whole bunch of your
team members out of Deb they'll hate you
for that they'll hate me for it yeah you
buy a program get your team members out
of Deb they'll hate you for that I
promise you oh that's so cool good for
y'all very well done Your Heroes
congratulations and thanks to you hall
for Furnishing it to you yeah and uh
we're proud to proud to have that
Association so very very well done you
guys good good work
all right we've got the live and give
box for you that includes the baby steps
millionaires book The Total Money
Makeover book and a Financial Peace
University membership for you to give
away uh you've been through the stuff in
smart dollar so you'll be able to keep
some of that and enjoy it some of it
you'll pass along to others well done
you guys we're very very proud of you
congratulations and we want to send our
love to Erica too who couldn't be with
us today she's with my sister but we
wanted to shout out to Erica well that's
why we did this that's right we did it
for Erica she's our reason that's right
good for y'all very well done all right
it's Eric and Elda Phoenix Arizona
100,000 paid off in 36 months count it
down let's hear a debt-free Scream 3 2 1
we're dead free
[Applause]
yeah that's how it goes down right
there love
it well if you're a company out there or
you work for a company which would be
all of you one of the two uh and you
want to have Smart dollar offered all
you got to do is just check it out at
ramseys solutions.com very easy to get
in touch with our team and they'd love
to help you help your team uh it's a
it's a Flawless system Costco's got all
their employees going through it I mean
we've got large companies like those but
most of the companies are not huge like
that most of them are regular siiz
companies and so uh but great those are
two great companies we're proud to have
and and uh and so if you want to be
involved in that the you know having
your company go through it is smart
dollar it meets all of the federal
guidelines meets all the Arisa
guidelines all the stuff you need to
know in that HR World we're up on it and
it's all dialed in so just check it out
at Ramsey solutions.com and look up
smartdollar that's what you're looking
for or slm dooll will get you there
either one this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
[Applause]
our scripture today Proverbs 15:22 plans
fail for lack of counsel but with many
advisors they succeed the old version
says in the multitude of council there
is safety I like
that kimens Wilson says My Success was
attended by quite a few failures along
the way but I refused to make the
biggest mistake of all worrying about
making
mistakes good like that our question of
today comes from neighborly your hub for
Home Services fall is a great time to
have air serve a neighborly company
clean your air ducts and make sure your
furnace is running properly before the
weather gets cold if you're in Nashville
too late uh learn more about air serve
at neighborly do.com Ramsey today's
question comes from Charlie in Georgia
I'm about to start interviewing
financial advisers I'm trying to find
someone that is not starting a career
but is my age or older is it wrong to
ask them their net worth they will know
what mine is basically I don't want a
broke person managing my money that's
interesting I don't know that I've heard
that one before asking your financial
adviser what their net worth is and
clearly he's an older individual we
don't know how old you know it's all
relative but he wants to work with
someone who's kind of in the same life
stage I guess as as him versus a young
buck who's just getting
started
H well I don't know what my smart bester
Pros net worth is I've never asked and
I've never been curious to be
honest um it's not a it's not
a bad question it's a little
awkward um trying to think
um I guess I don't correlate their
knowledge base with their income
necessarily which you know correlates
with their net I due to a degree um it'd
be nice to work with someone who you
know if they got $10 million I want to
know hey what are you doing you know
there's a piece of that that's
attractive yeah but you know
I
um I mean if they're if they're not if
they've been doing it 20 years and they
have any wealth then no I I would think
that I would correlate that lack of
results with their lack of knowledge cuz
that means they're making money mistakes
they're staying in debt for a long
period of time they're not doing the
stuff we're talking about they're notes
I mean CU if you do the stuff we talk
about for 20 years you're going to have
some net worth hello you know like
probably a million dollars or more um in
most every case so uh but I also don't
want him to be a player I don't want him
to be a Speculator a a high roller right
um and and the the last thing that comes
out of this Charlie is um you you made
one mistake in this I don't want a broke
person managing my money they're not
going to be managing your money you are
they're going to be doing what you tell
them to do so your job is to get someone
with the heart of a teacher they teach
you what to do and you approve the moves
so they're not managing anything without
your input so you're the one making the
decisions that you should never let
someone manage your money
blindly uh and so the only way they're
going to do the only thing they're going
to be putting money in is things you've
approved of agreed to um and they don't
make moves without your approval period
don't ever be in a situation otherwise
so in that sense but but I if I changed
your last sentence to I don't want
someone advising me on managing money
well when they
don't that's a fair statement I mean our
joke has always been you know um my
finance Professor is the one that taught
me to borrow money and he was broke
what's wrong with that it's like a shop
teacher with missing fingers right and
so that's what Charlie's pointing to
here I like your question Charlie I like
the the Crux of it I would want to
ensure somehow that they were practicing
steady proven time-honored investing
principles in their own lives um I've
just got the assurance that my guy is
doing that without knowing his net worth
so I don't know how you would get that
other than a net worth maybe just a
discussion to say okay you know I'm
concerned that you're actually
personally living the stuff that you and
I are talking about are you tell me that
you are and tell me how I know that uh
and and maybe they offer their net worth
at that point um but I I I it feels
awkward and
um I don't want to say
inappropriate but but from a manners
standpoint it feels inappropriate
yeah a wrong question so I don't I don't
know what to tell you I I've never had
this I have never asked I can tell you
that but I have assurance that they're
doing the things that they're telling me
to do there you go yeah I mean if you're
a financial coach the client doesn't you
know you ask the client hey what's your
income but the client doesn't ask you
well what's your income that's a weird
situation versus their money value vales
that's something that we can talk about
what are your values around debt are you
debt free you know versus specific
numbers that may not be as relevant yeah
I mean it's a little bit like your
doctor being 400 lbs 100% you know I
mean it's like huh kind of an issue here
in smoking yeah smoking 400 P that's
yeah it's something to think about you
know it's a fair it's a fair thing
Stockton is in Logan Utah hi Stockton
how are you I'm doing great thanks for
for taking my call than Ste George sure
what's up so um my father-in-law he's a
very kind man has a heart of gold but
he's broke and unemployed but he just
will not stop buying us gifts um and we
want to know you know should we approach
him about this should we talk to him and
sit down with him or should we just kind
of deny his gifts that he wants to give
us we're not sure how to how to help him
out of this how long you've been
married um it's been three uh three and
a half years yeah how old are you you I
am 27 okay you shouldn't do
anything your wife might it's her
dad yeah definitely you're just going to
be the smart like Punk that married his
daughter that's all he's going to
see I don't see that I don't think you
are but I but I'm telling you I don't
think he's going to hear this from you
but if she sat down and said Dad listen
we're trying to establish our household
here and it makes us really
uncomfortable able when you do these
gifts cuz we know you can't afford them
and it's very kind and you're a sweet
man dad and thank you for that but it
would really help us out if you would
limit that or stop doing it if she says
that he can hear that from his own kid
he won't hear it from you for for you
it's an
embarrassment yeah I I
agree so how do we I guess is there a
good way to approach that without
embarrassing him I mean he he just he
loves it gift giving is his love
language that's what I just said just
let her sit down with him by herself
with a cup of coffee and say Dad gift
giving is your love language you're a
sweet man and it's making us
uncomfortable because we know you can't
do it right now and we know you love us
you don't have to provide gifts to prove
it please
stop please stop or severely limit your
gifts your presence and your heart is
all we need in our lives we don't need
stuff from you please Dad stop it and if
she says that in private by herself with
her dad gently and kindly in great love
then it's not
embarrassing and um and she doesn't need
to say we that you you stay out of it
I'm telling you the closer you get to
this the less successful this
conversation is going to be oh I agree
yeah well she's not calling in today
which tells me you care more about this
than she does does she have the same
level of
concern she does she's just really
nervous to talk to him about it um m was
just a hard conversation Topic in their
home grown up and so um it's just really
hard for to bring it up yeah either
don't bring it up and just forget it and
don't worry about it or she brings it up
in private that's your only chance of
success I just I mean I think you just
added you added even more evidence that
it's not going to go well if you bring
it up because and the evidence is that
money's a source subject to start with
yeah and then Stockton this young dude
that married my daughters come marching
in here starts telling me stuff my
sons-in-law have been married to my
daughter for 10 years and 12 years and
um uh I doubt they would probably come
in and sit down with me without my
daughter having done so first on
something they were disagreeing about
they might and I wouldn't I wouldn't be
mad at them uh and I'm not saying that
it's just an awkward convers it's an
awkward relational connection Mo
daughters and mothers-in-law sons and
father in-law these are tough
connections and they can be done and and
I love my sons-in-law they love me I
think pretty sure they do well you give
them one gift back and that's The Total
Money Makeover maybe that'll help him oh
that'll be that' be adding insult to
injury yeah let's not do
that give them George's book in January
there we go break and free from broke
that helps that that'll do it uh that
puts us hour of the ramsy show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus